former Vice President Joe Biden is under
fire from rivals in the Democratic
presidential race after he reminisce
about working together with
segregationist senators back in the
1970s now this fight is suddenly brought
race into the center of this campaign
that O'Keefe is on Capitol Hill with
more on this story boy good morning to
you this is happening at a very critical
time it seems it sure is Gail these
racially charged incidents coming just
as the presidential campaign heads to
South Carolina in the coming days the
early primary state with the largest
bloc of black voters former Vice
President Biden Wednesday night stood by
comments he made this week about his
work with two segregationist senators
Herman Talmadge and James Eastland on
Tuesday at a fundraiser he discussed
working with them despite disagreements
on civil rights saying at least there
was some civility we got things done the
point I'm making is you don't have to
agree you don't have to like the people
in terms of their views but you just
simply make the case and you beat them
New Jersey senator Cory Booker another
2020 challenger called for an apology
Claire should apologize he knows better
they're not a racist bone in my body
I've been involved in civil rights my
whole career I don't understand why he
needs this lesson other 2020 candidates
also called out Biden I think it's just
it's misinformed and it's wrong we all
have to work with people with whom we
have very different points of view but I
think to be singing the praises of
people who were vicious segregationists
is not something that anybody what he
was talking about working with them is
that the same thing I'm not so sure
about that earlier senator Booker
testified at a House hearing on slavery
reparations held on the Juneteenth
holiday commemorating the end of slavery
and brokenhearted and angry right now
decades of living in a community where
you see how deeply unfair this nation is
still to so many people it's important
to note that Biden is finding some
important support south
Allina congressman james Clyburn and
other senior members of the
Congressional Black Caucus say that his
comments were taken out of context also
important to know that our CBS News
battleground tracker poll out this week
finds Biden has big advantages with
black voters over his Democratic rivals
Anthony yeah he's up 45 to 18 percent
over Sanders in our latest battleground
tracker poll and mayor Pete Budaj
has been absent from the campaign trail
trail this week dealing with an issue of
race in South Bend Indiana and what
what's happened there
yeah let's reiterate that he is the
mayor of that Indiana town and his he's
facing questions about the troubled
relationship between his Police
Department and the african-american
community there he addressed residents
yesterday about a shooting on Sunday a
fatal shooting of a black man who
prosecutors say was wielding a knife
critics say he's hidden from the
controversy supporters say he's been
transparent that same CBS News
battleground tracker poll finds black
voters and early primary States consider
him favorably just 13% and we just got
word Anthony he's been off to travel
last few days he's headed to Boston
today all right ed thanks very much